el congreso peruano le dio su voto de
confianza al gabinete ministerial del
presidente pedro castillo han votado a
favor de la cuestión de confianza 73
congresistas en contra 50 abstenciones 0
en consecuencia ha sido aprobada la
cuestión de confianza planteada por el
señor yo ha venido a darte presidente
del consejo de ministros la votación que
llegó luego de dos sesiones de debates
en el congreso se produjo por la poca
simpatía que algunos miembros del
gobierno tiene por el gabinete de guido
bellido presidente del consejo de
ministros
bellido es además investigado por una
supuesta apología al terrorismo en
mensajes que publicó en su cuenta en
facebook apoyando a un ex miembro del
grupo sendero luminoso minutos después
del voto el presidente peruano reacciona
en twitter es momento de incentivar un
profundo diálogo entre todas las raíces
políticas sobre todo con los sectores
más olvidados de nuestra sociedad
construyamos juntos un perú más justo en
total respeto de todas sus culturas y
sin discriminación entre sus ciudadanos
el jueves el debate en el congreso de
despertó reacciones en las calles de
lima a favor y en contra de la votación
los detractores del gobierno de pedro
castillo quien lleva apenas un mes en el
poder argumentan además que sus
representantes son los responsables del
alza de los precios y las dificultades
económicas de los peruanos
el resultado de la votación de este
viernes desactiva una crisis de gabinete
y una ausencia de diálogo entre los
poderes del estado que marcaron la
legislatura anterior con la disolución
del congreso y la caída de tres
presidentes